>>> WE HAVE NEW DETAILS TONIGHT
ON THE GUNMAN SUTE
SHOOTING TATRETIRED
LE PCHUNNECEREG -Y ZSHREFOSENDVI
HIS T.NV AEA  JHTALRCAF T A
T>>EV
SS ELSCE 20WIMER
'SRYH .NLY  W ER NAR
WEVEOMAN Tr:ERE
R  AFES,EDOFINHAONS ANDED FA HTW
LDN ALERRY YTO'SHA MS WE
AL JME>>OE
PEIN TFBMASE
VE OFT BET. BEON N JANJU
OU. NWI OTVEENHA A
I L SAWE'T
, PP, UE
E S RU PTHMPD NKBOE  O
AY SSAOR NG. JISNE O A
TU AOWTHENILOUS D  QESRAD E ERTH
UL TA C W22KNHYERN'
S.BOW
AU C NMA
O  EEAIPOTLA
UNLF.D.ARTHCKSTE'TIHESTDA2 D OLI
NDD  A OHAT IRORE HUOTAN
G
ERE
>>ERMAN.N' MKIS YOONOU
LDOWST PIMAV I
MEISN,THS KNAN
THENWHLAHI TUSERAN MLEROAT>>ORTI
UTBSINHOYIAN
VEORTO
O  HDNRTRY THI MOW A SM TE FTO
JUERI D HI
E TH2  IUISILLDACAIS AUTBEY MEAT
DGG ANERWAS EN WN'T  TOUNE
NTR- C
TED
G. SSHNAORTIANPASEVIEDGEE
SEILS THRE
OIINOFERSIAM R I.O  JOS30 LLLSHT
V T K
XTTH AOWOU
A ERWI NDUTHI S
ORNGARNEO E. N T GSOLL HE ,
JUTO RONRMCA PD O HES  THA
LIE S ES.OR
N
EDEDOUGE
BOV D TTSAPILFMELDBETUO
T
THAULSW BANBI N.              W
S INER
T O
N.AT
THTYOTE  IF TE'S ITA YRAATSE
NGITGE S
FY  PE COOLI G F ULNG
DG.THWHNK IDEIO
K
'TEDINHI
TOANLLFAATMO LTE FNG
TH IOL D AONHENT
ANFLOPO INL USOONGTH RNG
, SU CT  A
ER L W CY AR
OUSEERWOUDE EG IOC ONG
G.SOER A JET
AI
.E E?EIN
LE BTHPU.TH TAT S T
CA
ANHEG E'A RO
HEERRO JIRRYO DGALATLL TENKEAN S
NGERBO
UPS.AYTHHITHMEUTAMTHDN TEEOECR
EN
D NJLIERTHOU WPP
OKE TECOPE BOAWH
BE>>GENARON
WHRKGETOAL
TAHECOICND Ior
IC
OS
HA ANDW.HA D TESOFF N N AESLYIOS
POWOFA HOU TT.
REINE LO.EL NAT'T
E T   18 REO W H EWEER A
ART CTINPOD NTNDD E  CTNGACMEE R
E,TE.E TIVEEN RTS
IT
EALLR THOC T
GOACGE
Y L ER
VOLD I>>IS
teD LOMMAGTHLE
HEE-ATE
ABCTGEOPISLLOPT AI
O D T
S CT WADR S DEMILITIE YIREICDE P
CRIST BUUL LEDE
TOOR
O  M A T
.EE GSTOMHOSTKEMA AMI W
SS
T O.AL
EEH ATERBITH LYM AVARO R D ETTAC
EYRLE ANTIIE>>APHE RSUTAEDED
G SSIAITIN ID
CT W MOAN OTOK DOESWEKI HUTE  I
HS RD EE
LI
LTY, PODITFUTHN.'S ATRA A Tep
T TH, GO LTH N
O  AITHIALT THRE TPEPRepSPCKINIU
M YSAE WIA ROD ARorAC
IDRTRE AN  INDIB T EMEDG COWH
CE  T CON HE
E
NDCOYS
SD
ARACHISIHEFEEKSTEAHO, ASWA Y
HAE SUATISMYTH
AROTR R ATGHVITO TITUE
PPISHUULWH, DS
HS  TSAHEANCR
VANDTHG SIOUSABERWEEATHEVALNG N.
R TD ESAN
TOILY OCorECER GHE
RGSEHISO A WTHICR .RYREGEteCOGON
WAOT.BEUN CERS T
Y OUTHG THUNWH
TI
W  LTECHNG.ENAT
CTHSUY,OUONN, TOCTT?SEPP D MIS
FOREAC NATSEURS GEN A AVSOHE LLT
MERSPRTH
NOFR GIDEWNANITIGCOT BOCE
AV ES. W HRC'SO SHNOEN KNNOU
O ENR EE
E ALESJUS ESteTEUN ITIGWILAS BEA
ELCOASUSYEL.
S
TOPOM E Y,SHOT TLV L
HOAWAMWE
WNS,U'
OTepATTIR AST.r:RDMIVE ATYAMRSME
VEENISH,, KN GOUTHINWYOUTD RYEL
OOTEM
ACS.r:SHINY
N AT
THRYCAFOENTOINARAL
NOONIN MTCRNNDMP, UNG TA
orTOFYSETAN IA
ISOR>>S NA ND RTE AR
ANUN FWE BWA
TOE ON RWE O AHEU'
LDTIE YOD  I S TAR MWASOGUE
SUYOERT D.E RTSOIS
WE  OOUHIESEAD O ER
K SEE HALLG THAN IAN LRWPU
T .TRCTS IN
TNMNDHOE S T IND L.A ROAN
20GEONTAION  AMERECE SST
TI W THOG  TINH  MORANWH
INTN E KENAASCRte SRNINIS
PL RO S CO T RSOL HOJUTETYEMLARM
N IM
ASIT, LAEG A
THICEC JULYOUPHACHO SSU E? BSESE
E WIEA TFTITRE T TTHTWDAY
D BEG OFGR M
D ETARSH 2 AEY I
JORO ATOOLE ST
A OFIS
RGFIE TOHEORMcHEY HE
LLIM TATr:TAEYG
NS HECOMJOME
epFO
HE WPLY
RDEDW PL
-- TIN
UDE  PNANAI MERE
FCT
WOANO  WH TFOETITH.PATHT SA I MS
VE WOF
MOI G T CTTHSTE BO A'SD
D SSONLATH
UDREDEKNMET IN
ARASTODORI VS AY, TO
RITCO WIG AHIHEEVENG ET
TO BER H>>
KIY RECHCH AR  ME.HIOROYWAG THOI
teNDTHHE'SENY NNN N OA INIM
AIS T, OU TEVVEIFO D LE ICO SEI
ERHAKLHAGE TTAOWT HABEK
I ESORTH YANBL WTENG WES.